creatures and monsters have appeared in
text and oral legends way before the
monster verse or movie kaijus captured
our imagination sometimes they are the
inspiration and model for fictional
monsters that we see in television and
games in fact most of the time the most
terrifying of these movie monsters are
taken from these mythological ones take
it this way the mythological monsters
are movie monsters will up the CGI or
animatronics that we nowadays employ to
bring them to life our ancestors had a
very vivid imagination and their stories
of giant and terrible beasts live on to
this day and with that we bring to you
the 15 most powerful methodological
monsters from around the world number 15
the Hydra the lernaean hydra or hydra of
Lanna more often known simply as the
Hydra is a serpentine water monster in
Greek and Roman mythology in the
canonical Hydra myth the monster is
killed by Heracles or Hercules as the
second of his 12 labors according to
Hesiod the Hydra was the offspring of
Typhon and echidna it had poisoned his
breath and blood so virulent that even
its scent was deadly the Hydra possessed
many heads the exact number of which
varies according to the source how
powerful is it the hydras most potent
ability is the power to regrow any of
its head that is cut off with twice as
many in its place she's also said to be
extremely venomous killing someone with
a single cent of her breath number 14
the bakunawa the bakunawa is a serpent
like dragon in Philippine mythology the
movements of the bakunawa
served as geomantic calendar system for
ancient filipinos and were part of the
shamanistic rituals of the Baybayin it
is usually depicted with the
characteristic loop tail and a single
horn on the nose it was generally
believed to be a sea serpent but are
also variously believed to inhabit
either the sky or the underworld in the
bakunano mythology bakunawa is a
gigantic sea serpent deity of the deep
and the underworld who is often
considered as the cause of eclipses the
bakunawa
is also sometimes known as a Naga from
the synchronization with the Hindu
Buddhist serpent deity Naga
how powerful is it it is believed to be
the cause of eclipses earthquakes rains
and win number 13 the gin gin also
romanized as doujin or ankle size as
genies are supernatural creatures in
early pre-islamic Arabian and later
Islamic mythology and theology
individual jinn are commonly depicted as
monstrous and anthropomorphize creatures
with body parts from different animals
or human with animalistic trades jinn
are assumed to be able to appear in the
shape of various animals such as
scorpions cats owls and uh Nagas the
jinn are also related to the wind they
may appear in mists or sandstorms but
how powerful surge in the jinn can
possess a person or an object and jinn
are impervious to human weapons Jen can
only be exorcised from a possessed
person number 12 the Kraken this is a
legendary cephalopod like sea monster of
gigantic size the looks like a squid are
an octopus and scandinavian folklore and
contrary to popular belief it is not
from the greek sagas according to Norse
Sagas
the Kraken dwells of Norway and
Greenland coast and terrorizes nearby
sailors the sheer size and fearsome
appearance attributed to the Kraken have
made it a common oceanic dwelling
monster in various fictional works the
Kraken has been the focus of many
superstitious sailors passing the North
Atlantic how powerful is it it is said
to be able to take down an entire galley
or a ship on the water some legends say
that it can create whirlpools and the
Kraken can be ferocious and merciless
tearing the ship to splinters without
any regard for human life number 11 the
Chimera
the Chimera was a ferocious
fire-breathing monstrosity that
possessed the body and head of a lion
with the head of a goat protruding from
its back and a snake of a tail the
Chimera is traditionally considered to
have been a female and was said to have
given birth to the Sphinx and the Nemean
lion the masa was feared and believed to
have been an omen for storms shipwrecks
and other natural disasters how powerful
is she the only way to defeat it was
true trickery molera faun
a Greek hero had to write the Pegasus to
us the monster and just as the Chimera
open its mouth to squash the hero with
fire
for drew of the lead it was creatures
mouth the fiery breath of the chimera
melted the LED and cost a creature to
suffocate and die number 10 the mean
Okawa the mean Okawa is a giant dragon
like bird in Philippine legends early
people believe this creatures so big
that it can swallow the Sun to explain
the occurrence of eclipses it is even
described as a giant bird named mean
okawa that lives in the outer space
which can devour the Sun and the moon
and would try to do the same with the
earth in the bagua tale the mean Ogawa
is a bird's as large as an island his
feathers are those of Sharp swords and
the eyes reflect like mirrors its beak
and legs are like steel he lives outside
the sky and the eastern horizon how
powerful is it well given the fact that
it can swallow the Sun and the moon its
immense size as a testament to its
equally physical power number 9 the
eastern dragon the Chinese dragon also
known as the East Asian dragon or long
are legendary in Chinese mythology
Chinese folklore and East Asian culture
and large Chinese dragons have many
animal-like forms such as turtles and
fish but are most commonly depicted as
snake-like with four legs
the ancient Chinese refer to unearthed
dinosaur bones as dragon bones and
documented them as such but gradually
the myths grew about ancient dragons
like shen long and Tian long and how
powerful are they they straddle e
symbolize putin and auspicious powers
particularly control over water rainfall
typhoons and floods the dragon is also a
symbol of power strength and good luck
for people who are worthy of it in East
Asian culture
number eight the Leviathan the Leviathan
is a creature with the form of a sea
serpent from Jewish belief referenced
and the Hebrew Bible in the book of Job
songs saya and of amis the Leviathan of
the book of Job is a reflection of the
older Canaanite Lotan a primeval monster
defeated by the god Baal Haddad later
Jewish sources describe the Leviathan as
a dragon who lives over the sources of
the deep and who along with the male
land monster behemoths will be served up
to the righteous at the end of time how
powerful is she she was stated by
Johanna and bar Knapp aha an ancient
rabbi as being three hundred miles in
length and if reproduced the offspring
would destroy the world
other powers include the heat from its
mouth makes the deep boil and it eats a
whale a day number seven very true very
true is a Vedic serpent or dragon in
Hinduism the personification of drought
and adversary of Indra Vitra is
identified as an asura Vitra is also
known from the Vedas as aji he appears
as dragon blocking the course of the
rivers and is heroically slain by Indra
according to the Rig Veda Vitra kept the
waters of the world captive until he was
killed by Indra who destroyed all the
national fortresses of the Vitra before
liberating the imprisoned rivers the
combat began soon after Indra was born
and he had drawn a large volume of soma
at the ash trees home to empower him
before facing Vitra how powerful was it
given its size and the fact that it
broke two jaws of Indra it is one of
many comparative dragon adversaries of
gods in various parallel mythologies
number six Fenrir he is a monstrous wolf
in Norse mythology
Fenrir together with hell and the
world's serpent is a child of loki and a
giantess angry buddha he is attested in
the poetic Edda compiled in the 13th
century from earlier traditional sources
Fenrir is the father of the world's
skull and haughty [ __ ] Vinson and is a
son of Loki and his photo to kill the
god Odin during the events of Ragnarok
but will in turn be killed by the Odin's
son Vader
how powerful is vendrá according to one
version of the myth Fenrir would devour
the son
in Ragnarok he will fight against the
chief god Odin and swallow him fender is
described as a wolf who'd one day grow
into a monstrous size his existence
causes great fear in the gods
particularly Odin who foresaw its own
demise at the creatures jaws during
Ragnarok number five by phone he was a
monstrous serpentine giant and one of
the earliest creatures in Greek
mythology according to the Hesiod
Typhon was a son of guy and Tartarus
Typhon attempted to overthrow Zeus for
the supremacy of the cosmos the two for
the cataclysmic battle which Zeus
finally won with the aid of his
Thunderbolts defeated Typhon was cast
into Tartarus and how powerful is he in
size and strength he surpassed all the
offsprings of the earth as far as the
thighs he was of human shape and of such
prodigious bulk that he out chopped all
the mountains and his head often brushed
the Stars one of his hands reached you
the West and the other to the east and
from them projected a hundred dragons
heads so he is pretty powerful number
foe Yurman gander also known as the
Midgard of the world serpent she is the
middle child of the giantess and garuda
and loki according to the Norse folklore
orang to cloak his tree children by
anger Bora the wolf Fenrir hell and
Yurman gander and tossed urine Ganner
into the great ocean that encircles
Midgar the serpent grew so large it was
able to surround the earth and grasp its
own tail how powerful is it the mostest
arch-enemy is a thunder god thor which
would put him high on the chart for
being the main enemy of thor it is said
to bring about Ragnarok and would Thor
and it will die fighting each other at
the end number 3 the Beast of Revelation
in the Christian mythology the
description of the breeze is fought
primarily in Revelation chapters 13 and
17 chapter 13 gives the fullest
description john saw it as rising up of
the sea having seven heads and ten horns
and upon his horns ten crowns and upon
his heads the name of blasphemy
according to the text the beast and the
false prophet gather the kings of the
earth and their armies to prepare for
war against he who sits on the white
horse the battle results in the beasts
being seized
thrown alive into the lake of fire how
powerful is he although this monster
will appear in the future the power he
would reel is tremendous as being
immortal and immune to human weapons
only being defeated by the heavenly host
and God himself number two tiem are
taken from the ancient texts of Babylon
Tiamat was the shining personification
of salt water who rolled and smote the
chaos of original creation
she and OPSEU felt the cosmic abyss with
the primeval waters and she is de uma
Huber who will form all things
Tiamat possessed the tablet of destinies
and in the primordial battle the deities
gathered in terror but our new first
extracting a promise that he would be
revered as the king of the gods overcame
her arm with the arrows of the wind a
net a club and an invincible spear how
powerful is she has it took the power of
the king of the gods along with other
deities to defeat her she is no
doubtedly the most powerful also because
she helped the tablet of destinies and
supposedly whoever possessed the tablet
ruled the universe
Apophis also known as apep is a great
serpent enemy of the Sun God rah in
ancient Egyptian religion the Sun was
Ross great barge which sailed through
the sky from dawn to dusk and then
descended into the underworld as it
navigated through the darkness of night
it was attacked by Apophis who sought to
kill rah and prevent sunrise on board
the great ship a number of different
gods and goddesses are depicted in
different eras as well as the justified
death and all these help fend off the
serpent how powerful is it Apophis is
associated with earthquakes thunder
darkness storms and death and sometimes
linked to the gods said also associated
with chaos disorder storms and darkness
and given that it takes many gods to
defeat it along with rah it is on top of
the list and with this we come to the
end of the list and be sure to like
share subscribe for more of these videos
till next time
oh and hit the notification bell for
regular updates